You're probably pretty familiar
at this point with
how to solve two equations
and two unknowns.
Let's say we had the equation
2x, I don't know, minus y is
equal to 10.
And let's say you had x
plus 3y is equal to 5.
And there are a lot of different
ways to solve it.
And visually, the representation
we use in our
heads, is that this represents
a line, and this
represents a line.
And if they're not parallel to
each other, they're going to
intersect at a unique point.
And that unique point will
be the solution.
That unique x and y will be
the point where these two
lines intersect.
And so one way that we can solve
these is we can multiply
either of these equations
by scalars, by numbers.
And we have to multiply both
sides of the equation, and
then add them to the
other equation.
So what we could do, and we do
it in such a way is that we
eliminate variables.
So for example, let's
say we wanted to get
rid of the y term.
So we could take this equation
and then add it to what?
So we have a 3y here.
So then if we made this into a
minus 3y, when you add the
two, you would get 0.
The y's would eliminate.
Let me do it this way.
If you multiply this top
equation by 3, you get 6x
minus 3y is equal to 30.
Multiply both sides by 3.
And the bottom equation we're
keeping the same.
x plus 3y is equal to 5.
And then you just add the two.
So 7x.
That's a 0, is equal to 35.
I picked these numbers at
random, but it seems that they
actually work out.
So we get x is equal to 5.
And then you could go back, and
you take this, and you can
substitute it back into either
one of these equations.
So you would have-- let's
do the first one.
2 times 5 minus y
is equal to 10.
10 minus y is equal to 10.
y would be equal to 10, right?
10 minus 0 is 10.
And it's true here in this
equation as well.
So that's how you solve two
equations of two unknowns.
So how do you do it with
three equations?
So I have here-- let
me write it down.
I designed this equation, so
it's actually reasonably
straightforward to solve.
You have minus x plus 2y
minus z is equal to 9.
I have 3x minus 7y minus 2z
is equal to minus 20.
And I have 2x plus 2y plus
z is equal to 2.
Now first of all, what's the
visual representation of this?
And if you watched the intuition
when I talked about
the video on the intuition of a
three variable integration,
you know that each of these
represent a plane in three
dimensions.
And so, if you're trying to
figure out what x, y, and z
satisfy all three of these
equations, you're essentially
saying, what point in
three-dimensional space exists
on all three of these planes?
And that point is essentially
the intersection of these
three planes.
And that's very hard to draw,
so I won't do it now.
But you might want to watch
that visual intuition--
intuition video that I did.
But anyway, let's go to
actually solving it.
So solving three equations and
three unknowns, you actually
do the same thing as
you did with two
equations and two unknowns.
It's just a lot messier.
And it's just a little bit more
confusing in terms of
which variable do you need
to eliminate, and when.
And because of that, it's very,
very, very important to
be systematic about it.
So the way I like to do it is,
I like to-- and this is
actually called Gaussian
elimination, or Gauss-Jordan
elimination, and it's done a
little bit more formally in
linear algebra.
But essentially, I like to
eliminate the two x's in these
two equations, and then
I like to eliminate
this y in this equation.
So all you're left
with is a z here.
And then you'd have z
equals something.
Then you can substitute into
this equation, then you can
substitute for y.
And then you could substitute
the y and the z back to this
equation, and solve for x.
So let's do that.
I know that sounds a little
daunting, but I think if we
actually do the problem, it'll
be a little bit more
straightforward.
So before we break into the
mechanics, I want to show you
something else.
And this is-- depending when
you're doing this, your
teacher might be upset or
impressed that you do this--
but this is just an easier
way to save time.
It's to write an augmented
matrix that represents these
three equations of
three unknowns.
And what do I mean by that?
We're going to be rewriting
these over and over again.
And instead of writing an x, a
y, a z, and the equal sign
every time, let's just write
the numbers that matter.
So we can represent this as-- So
minus x, we could say this
is minus 1, 2, minus 1.
And this is called an
augmented matrix.
Because we'll put a 9 here.
So this just says, minus x plus
2y minus z is equal to 9.
And then we say 3x minus 7y
minus 2z is equal to minus 20.
I'm not doing anything here.
I'm just rewriting it in a form
that has a little bit
less letters in it.
And then the last equation
is 2x plus 2y plus
z is equal to 2.
So the first thing I said that
wanted to do, is I wanted to
eliminate these two
x terms. Right?
Remember, these just correspond
to these two terms.
So how do I do that?
Well I'm going to keep the top
equation the same, minus x,
plus 2y minus z is equal
to positive 9.
That's just that equation.
And remember, you could
write it out.
You could rewrite these with
x's and y's all the time.
I'm just doing this for a little
bit of simplicity.
And your teacher actually
might do it this way.
So that's more useful.
And I like to do it this way.
So how can we eliminate this 3x
here, or this 3 right here?
Well what if we took this
equation, and added it to 3
times this equation?
Or another way, we substituted
this equation with this
equation, plus 3 times
this equation.
So what happens?
So we take each of these terms,
and add to it 3 times
each of these terms. So 3x plus
3 times minus x, that is
equal to 0.
Right?
I'm just multiplying this top
equation by 3, and adding it
to this equation.
So minus 3x plus 3x-- Let me
actually do it one time, just
so you see what I'm doing.
I just multiplied this
top equation by 3.
So you get minus 3x plus 6y
minus 3z is equal to 27.
And I'm adding that to this.
So minus 3x plus 3x is 0.
6y minus 7y is equal
to minus y.
And then minus 3z plus minus
2z is equal to minus 5z.
This is very computationally
intensive, you can tell.
And then 27 plus minus 20,
that's just equal to 7.
I'm going to dwell on this step
a little bit, because I
really want you to understand
what I'm doing.
Because if you understood what
I just did in this step,
you'll understand the rest
of this video, frankly.
So I just replaced this
equation-- which is the same
thing as this equation--
with this equation
plus 3 times this.
So I said, 3 plus 3 times
negative 3 is 0.
Minus 7 plus 3 times
2 is minus 1.
Minus 2 plus 3 times
minus 1 is minus 5.
Minus 20 plus 3 times 9 is 7.
Hopefully that makes sense.
So now, let's do the
same thing here.
Let's try to eliminate
this 2x.
So if you want to eliminate this
2x, we could take this
equation and add to it 2
times this equation.
So what will happen?
We'll have 2 plus
2 times minus 1.
That's 0.
2 plus 2 times 2.
Well that's 6.
And then we have 1 plus
2 times minus 1.
Well that's minus 1.
Right?
2 times minus 1 is minus 2.
1 minus 2 is minus 1.
And then 2 plus 2 times 9.
So that's 2 plus 18.
So that's 20.
And once again, we could
rewrite this
equation right here.
This middle equation right
here is the same thing as
minus y minus 5z
is equal to 7.
Just so you remember, this is
just another representation of
these actual linear equations.
I just don't feel like writing
the x's, y's, and z's and the
equal signs.
But anyway, now let's see
if we can eliminate
this term down here.
So how could we do that?
Well we could add this equation,
we could substitute
this equation with this equation
plus 6 times this
one, right?
Because if you have this plus
6 times this, you'd
have 6 minus 6.
And you'd get a 0 here.
So let's do that.
Let's write the augmented
matrix.
We're not changing
the top line.
So we get minus 1x plus 2y
minus z is equal to 9.
We're actually not even changing
this equation.
So we're getting 0x minus y
minus 5z is equal to 7.
And now we're replacing this
with this plus 6 times this.
So the 0 plus 6 times 0 is 0.
6 plus 6 times minus 1.
That's 6 minus 6.
That's 0.
Minus 1 plus 6 times minus 5.
That's minus 1 minus 30.
So it's minus 31.
And then we have 20
plus 6 times 7.
So that's 6 times 7 is 42.
So that's 62.
Now we're actually almost
done solving.
What can we do here?
So I just want to make sure you
understand our position.
What is this last equation?
This 0, 0, minus 31, line 62?
Well, this last equation is just
minus 31z is equal to 62.
And so we can divide both sides
of this equation by
minus 31, and we'd get z
is equal to minus 2.
But if we were to do that using
our augmented matrix
notation, we would just say,
well let's just divide both
sides of this bottom equation
by minus 31.
And we would get minus
1, 2, minus 1, 9, 0,
minus 1, minus 5, 7.
So we're dividing this
one by minus 31.
So it's 0, 0, 1, minus 2.
And there you have it.
So we have at least
solved for z.
Right?
This equation is the same thing
as this one. z is equal
to minus 2.
Now at this point, what we
have just done using this
augmented matrix, this is called
Gaussian elimination.
Now we can continue this.
And we can eliminate
this term, this
term, and this term.
And it would be called
Gauss-Jordan elimination.
Or, we could use the fact that
z is equal to minus 2.
And then we could substitute
back into this equation to
solve for y.
And then we'd have our
values for y and z.
And we could substitute back
into this equation.
Let's do it that way,
just for kicks.
So this is called upper
row echelon form.
I always forget the terminology,
but let's keep
this equation in mind.
And let me erase all of
this, so we have some
room to work with.
I can't do anything without
some room to work with.
Let me even erase
this up here.
And as you can tell,
this is very
computationally intensive.
And it's not my cup of tea.
It's not what I would
want to do if I had
the weekend to myself.
But anyway, let me write these
equations in kind of this
format, so we can kind of go
back to our traditional world.
So this equation right
here, this is
actually the same equation.
We never changed it.
Minus x plus 2y minus
z is equal to 9.
This equation is minus y
minus 5z is equal to 7.
And then this equation is
z is equal to minus 2.
So we solved for z.
This equation essentially
solves for z.
And now we can substitute
back into this one.
So we have minus y minus 5 times
z, which is minus 2, is
equal to 7.
So minus y plus 10
is equal to 7.
Minus y is equal to minus 3.
y is equal to 3.
There we have it.
We solved for z and y.
And now we could substitute
the y, the z into this top
equation, and solve for x.
So what do we have?
And then we're done.
Let's see.
Minus x plus 2 times y, so 2
times 3, minus z-- minus minus
2, that's z-- is equal to 9.
So minus x plus 6 plus
4 is equal to 9.
Mine x plus 10 is equal to 9.
Minus x is equal to minus
1, or x is equal to 1.
So the solution-- oh my God.
My phone is ringing.
So many people calling me.
I think it's my wife.
She might be downstairs.
We're supposed to go eat out.
But anyway, let me
just finish this.
So the solution to this 3 by 3
equation is the point x is
equal to 1, y is equal to 3,
and z is equal to minus 2.
And that's the unique point in
three-dimensional space that
lies on all three
of these planes.
Or the unique point where these
three planes intersect.
Anyway, I hope you got that.
And it's time for me to go
have dinner with my wife.
See you soon.